those are sisters from France where they
are asked to remove the hijabi evil
people who do not even allow a Muslim
woman to observe her hijab they are
trying to strip you not of your hijab
they are trying to strip you not of your
Abaya they are trying to strip you of
your Islam
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me when I'm doing boxing when I'm
joking when I'm doing bodybuilding this
can benefit you it's shilajit from
Nature's Blends as you guys know I get
my honey my black seed oil and many
other supplements from them it has 86
plus minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women like Allah
doesn't start the Surah Toba with
Bismillah I'm not going to start this
video with any Greetings or anything
like that
these evil evil countries I watched this
video and it boiled my blood
wallahi I felt like driving to France
and going to that school and standing in
front of that school and telling the
sisters don't take your hijabs off my
dear sisters don't take it off don't let
this evil corrupt government who
believes in freedom of speech Yes or
freedom of addressing how you want of
course you can I mean if you are a woman
boy who wants to transition into a girl
and wants to dress up in a mini skirt
you go ahead if you want to you know cut
your body parts whatever it may be
because you feel like you are you feel
like you are a woman or a man you go
ahead take puberty blockers harm your
body it's all good wear mini skirts
bikini walk naked it's all good but if
you wear the hijab no no no here is the
video that will boil your blood may
Allah destroy these people may Allah
destroy these people who oppress people
just because they want to obey their
lord look at this video and tell me it
doesn't boil your blood
[Music]
this is the sign my sisters subhanallah
those are sisters from France where they
are asked to remove the hijab before
going into a school subhanallah but what
you are saying is actually worse than
what you think they are those videos are
from the news asking this country to
forbid even the obeyer that they worry
like why are they removing the scarf and
not the Abaya this is what they're
talking about this is the sign for you
my sisters to be grateful to Allah to be
observant with you hija because those
girls will give anything to have your
right to wear the hijab properly
properly the neck the arms with the sun
coming sisters be strong and be grateful
you guys see that
well like our sisters
and I'm trying to be balanced here I'm
not trying to go at them but
one line like this I'm so sure this
might sound selfish this might sound
just in the moment I'm just being
Russian
while it's better you don't go to school
it is better that you do not score
school and take that hijab off Allah
will provide for you if your parents are
sending you to school because they see
that as more important and they see that
as more important than you wearing the
hijab
um
be respectful to your parents I'm not
asking you guys to be rude to your
parents but I don't know where the
head's at I don't know where the head's
out
you know what this means and I talk
about this over and over again and
people think I talk talk about for the
sake of it do you know what taking the
actual over the knuckle means yeah let
me tell you what it means it means that
you do not have enough trust what Allah
has told you and that he will take care
of you and he will provide for you that
you would rather send your daughters to
school and tell them teacher okay take
your what can we do you need to study
you need to stop isn't the vast Allah's
Earth vast enough look what Allah says
in the Quran when the angel sees their
souls of those who were wronged who have
wronged themselves
scolding them what do you think you were
doing they will reply we were oppressed
in the land the angels will respond was
Allah's Earth not spacious enough for
you to immigrate it is they who will
have the hell as their home what's an
evil destination now I'm not applying
this Ayah to those because Allah says in
the Quran except helpless men women and
children who could not afford a way out
yet it is right to hope that Allah won't
pardon them for Allah is the most
forgiven very merciful okay whoever
emigrates in the cause of Allah will
find many safe heavens and bountiful
resources throughout the Earth those who
leave their homes and thou while
immigrating to Allah and his messenger
their reward has already been secured
with Allah and Allah is forgiving most
merciful brothers and sisters I'm not
applying this Hadith to them I mean it's
Quran to them this is the promise of
your lord
if your dean and I found out that
subhanallah these people are now
petitioning
petitioning saying what taking the hijab
is not enough why they wearing the buyer
my dear sisters in France or brothers
and sisters in France
put your Deen first
yes you might come and see yeah bro at
least easy for you look I'm living in
the west myself yeah the point is what
are you going to send your children
what's going to be next women's skirts
you're going to let your daughters wear
mini skirt your brothers shave their
beards off whatever it may be
what is going on do you know you don't
have trust in his words he Allah said he
will provide for you in many places his
Earth is vast
if you are gonna put the Dunya before
the Hereafter You're Gonna Lose the
Dunya and the Hereafter they're going to
humiliate you
and this is an evidence that shows these
people do not give a damn about freedom
of speech they don't care the ummah of
comfort is one then one all they want is
you do not practice your religion that's
all they care about do not practice your
religion and outright enemy
and if we're going to do that I would
rather not send my children to school
you know why because I know Allah will
provide do you not ever compromise your
religion at the cost of this place in
Allah
Allah will humiliate
they are now trying to go for their
abias let them show their body yes
sexual objects sexual objects that's
what they are that's what they want you
can see the book Beauty sick sexual
object Beauty sick yes these girls are
Beauty six sleeping around going and
sleeping around with men for validation
because they feel like they're not good
enough this is what the Western world is
doing to the woman they're treating them
like toilets you're a walking toilet
when a man wants to ejaculate you come
let me ejaculate inside you now you can
go this is the level they want to drop
the woman down to this is what you want
a walking toilet and Islam is there to
honor and that's why more people come to
Islam which are women than men
you will be questioned do not compromise
your religion yes if you are after the
worldly gays and my daughter needs to
study and get this and that and she has
to be a lawyer understand to hell with a
degree to hell with his degree your son
whoever it is to hell
none of this is going to matter on your
makayama Allah is going to ask you and I
swear upon the lord of the Kaaba I swear
from The Lord of the Kaaba Allah will
give you a way out put your trust in
trust in him not your limited mind and
if they are oppressing you to discover
migrate migrate I know some sister
sister soul who comes to our podcast
yeah she left France for that reason she
left may Allah deal with this in these
individuals these scones and this macron
without spit in his face all the spit in
his face his evil people who do not even
allow a Muslim woman a Muslim woman to
observe her hijab they are trying to
strip you not of your hijab they are
trying to strip you not of your Abaya
they are trying to strip you of your
Islam wake up or Muslims in France
there's 10 million of you wake up
wake up do not send your daughters
taking their hijabs off to go to school
to hell with their school Allah will
provide for them Allah will provide for
them that's Allah's promise the biggest
insult to Allah is that you make it seem
as if Allah has created the heavens and
the Earth there are billions of galaxies
in our universe and he cannot provide
for you daughter that you have to send
him to school and my dear sisters who
are doing this I know you guys hate it I
know you guys don't want to I assume the
best I know but it's heartbreaking for
us to see that they are making you guys
do that may Allah destroy them may Allah
destroy them that's all I'm going to say
and that Ayah that I read to the parents
who are watching this
don't send your children to school do
not send them to school if they're going
to make them do that well lie you don't
voila he don't Allah will give you a way
out like Allah says if you fear me I
will give you a way out from places you
can never imagine and where are all
those feminists where are the Liberals
defending these women's rights to wear
the hijab you Hypocrites you double
standard hypocrite two-faced cowards